why the power of castle hates skulls
and guess what
you're here and so am i and i'm so glad
that you tuned in today because
we have another episode in which i have
so many things to talk about so many
exciting events and ideas to discuss
with you that i may not be able to fit
it in within just the normal three-hour
time span that this podcast normally
runs now i'd like to start today
by sharing something that was shared
with me early this morning from my
producer casey i wake up to a text
normally he might text me something
business related like what time are we
starting you know will you be two hours
late or three hours late today who knows
right can we just can you give me a
ballpark are you still doing the podcast
mark hello nobody's heard from you in
six days what's going on are you harming
yourself
did you finally overdose on anabolics
what he actually sent me was
this little video here
and just the caption hella old harley
now
some of these things they sting because
they're accurate you know so this goes
yep his hair does look like mine if i
manage to keep most of it this is a dude
who's just
in what the british might call a budgie
smuggler
what americans might call a very small
red speedo
he's got to what's your guess on his age
i'm going to say 70s yeah it's going to
say 75 yeah like push in 80 for sure
just based on
i don't he's got the distended gut thing
going you know he looks like a
malnourished african child or any child
that's malnourished let's not say that
that's just in the cultural zeitgeist
the pictures that are used to manipulate
our emotions and and give to you know
the hungry across the world i think it's
relevant because it looks just like you
thank you for breaking that down
it is true now i was going to say
it does look like me
the thing that the first thought that
came to my head was but casey i'll never
have legs that skinny
four feet that big right
oh
that's amazing so yeah i do often look
at guys like that where i'm like
if only if only i could like
stop working out my legs and they would
actually just get to a normal size you
know
i'm not mad at having muscular legs it
would be nice to have the option to just
have normal sized legs i think i'm gonna
put this video to the song uh the haters
will say song that you dude that's an
amazing idea
and if you see that later today
this is where it all started
fantastic i just love waking up and
being mocked that's my favorite thing
um
so
let me give you a little slight recap of
some of the things i've been doing this
week
such as workouts this morning i had a
leg day and
i've been working out at six in the
morning as i might have mentioned before
with my clients paul who uh i
tend to
work out with because he likes that and
also offers me an opportunity to at
least get a few workouts at each week
even if i don't make it to other
sessions now he's recovering from a hip
replacement so
what happens is he's we mostly just do
leg press and hamstring curls leg
extensions calf raises simple stuff
however when you wake up at 5 30 to go
do legs you know
mark might not be in the best mood going
to do that
i want to chime in and say still do it
still wake up and go through the motions
because it might even take you half an
hour i was inside the gym
walking through the leg press
still essentially in a bad mood about
having to wake up and go
do legs at this hour you really your
self-talk at that point is like i don't
want to do this
f this i'm not in the mood i want to
reschedule yada yada and that sometimes
lasts for a few minutes maybe if you get
a full night's rest and you know you're
excited about something else you wake up
and you're ready to go to the gym in the
morning that does sometimes happen but
if you've got a lot going on or you
didn't get all the sleep that you wanted
etc you can wake up and
your brain is really telling you no
don't do this do anything else but this
and i'm gonna encourage you experiment
with just
pushing back on that a little bit give
it give it five 10 15 minutes or in my
case this morning 30 to 45 minutes now
i will say this it lasted up until
basically
the first set of leg press i did even
with just four plates
it was uncomfortable i didn't like it my
knee felt like it was in pain
it was
feeling stressful on my joints my groin
going down into it you know the bottom
position of the leg press but then each
set as i'm going up plate by plate
it somehow felt easier
now that could be the diana ball rushing
through my veins but it could also just
be the fact you're getting blood of the
area your circulation is increasing your
heart rate goes up a little bit you get
a little bit of that stimulation
the rain body fuel finally kicks in
and
by the end of the workout you're not
regretting it you don't have to go nuts
i didn't go super heavy i went up to
like seven plates which is moderate for
me
and even if i'm not going up to a new
weight one of the things i do is focus
on something simple even as simple as
breathing and form on a leg press you're
thinking it's a machine
how much form can you use well
i try to pause at the end of each rep i
try to make each rep identical i try to
bring my knees back into my chest
in a very standard way and measure how
deep i'm going mentally with physical
cues like my leg is pushing into
my nipple i'll be honest
and
from there i just try to make each rep
the same and focus on high quality reps
right another day of michael heavier but
today it was just about depth it was
about breathing and that is still
progress and then i hit the sun
afterwards
try to do that every day feels fantastic
and i recommend that for everybody i
will talk we'll continue to talk about
the benefits of sauna but really you
know uh exercise mimicking effects
longevity effects
uh it feels amazing coming out of asada
that's really the benefit you walk out
and you're like man regular air is
fantastic
okay
what else i got i just watched the ricky
gervais special have you seen that casey
i have okay what do you think of it i
thought it was great yeah classic uh
ricky gervais right
and so you know one of those things
where i go i don't know how much
controversy there really is
from
people outside of a few hyper
opinionated voices but you watch it and
a few takeaways
that i loved were how he
like explains satire you know it's like
for anybody watching this to criticize
me this is how jokes work and does it
right off the bat right off the bat yeah
so you're like you know and to summarize
this poorly he basically says
we know that the thing we're saying is
bad and that's why we're all in on the
joke and it's funny and it's not just me
up here giving a lecture on how i feel
about a minority group or something like
that whatever you're taking offense to
and of course calls out and like you
know this is the part that you're going
to talk about or report on or try to
cancel me over or whatever it's
fantastic to have people like him in a
position where uh
he's just too rich to cancel
he's already made it he can say whatever
he wants but he does it well and that's
always the thing where i go
you know unlike somebody coming out and
just doing something edgy for the sake
of it
let's say like mock kobe bryant's death
or something on the day it happens well
this guy
he he backs everything up that he says
and he uses wit he uses a fantastic
writing he he understands the elements
of humor
uh which allows him to take things as
far as he can and i love the throwaway
lines throughout where he's like you
know i'm gonna come out and go on a limb
here but i don't like racism
and yeah i'll set stuff up with like say
what you will about hitler right say
yeah
phenomenal
here's a definition because
you know
usually the battle these days over over
comedy has to do with wokeness right but
wokeness is a term that gets thrown
around a lot
that can mean different things to
different people
at different times i heard a definition
this week that i really liked that i
want everybody to chew on wokeness
refers to the invocation of unintuitive
and morally burdensome political norms
and ideas in a manner which suggests
they are all self-evident this idiom or
perhaps communicative register replaces
the obligation of persuading others to
adopt our values with the satisfaction
of signaling our allegiances and
literacy to those who already agree
in some cases this means we speak in an
insular language that alienates those
who haven't stewed in the same activist
cultural milieu
at other times it means we express
fealty to a novel or unintuitive norm
and suggests that anyone who doesn't
already agree with it
is a bad person
i think that covers it because i always
challenge people like what do you mean
when you say this or that when you say
woke this is probably the best
definition i've seen which means that
you come in you know
and essentially beat people over the
head with unintuitive ideas as if
they're intuitive
and rather than going i want to bring
you to my side by convincing you that
i'm right
your expression isn't meant to persuade
it's meant to simply communicate to
others that you're a good person because
you already agree get it
and that comes into play because
you know
what's the opposite of woke sort of
being blatantly racist i guess
um innocent i mean they're both like you
know i would if you're excessively woke
obviously i think that's kind of a
something that most people see through
as empty virtual signaling and on the
other side of that if you're just
blatantly racist that's not great either
a bunch of people were messaging me
about an incident that happened recently
in north hollywood at a gym called no
limit fitness a gym that i've been to
that i've posted videos from that i
think is a fantastic gym
full of bright colors it's like
fluorescent kind of miami look to it uh
the equipment's great all the stuff i'd
only been there this one time now uh
it's owned by a guy
an armenian guy who i actually met when
i was there
and he unfortunately
you know has some some views and some
expressions that most people would
consider blatantly racist he was caught
on video
at the grand opening sort of celebration
of his gym referring to somebody like
there was juice vendors i guess outside
the gym
and he was like
why are these
why are these mexican juice vendors here
this is not fancy get them out of here i
don't want mexicans at my like a
sentiment like that you only capture a
few sentences of it but
it obviously went viral
the gym kind of shuts down for a period
of time he issues a standard apology on
instagram etc
and
i just wanted to say he gives juice
heads a bad name all right um
no i'm just kidding more than that he
it's unfortunate and i feel like when
people sent me this stuff i'm like that
really it hurts to see because of the
condescension you know because of the
sort of attitude of like
it's not just whatever if you want to
take another side of like you know the
girl goes on stage at a kendrick lamar
concert and
sings along to
kendrick's song and uses the n word and
it's like that's like a misunderstanding
or an oops moment or something like that
on the spectrum of
racist incidents that are caught on
camera you go okay i feel bad for that
she didn't intend to hurt anybody
whatever when you see something like
this
it feels more
like
he's expressing disgust at who these
people are for trying to make a living
in the world right and uh it takes the
position that i'm better than you and
you're selling this whole event just
with your mere presence and your mere
ethnicity so it's one of these things
where you go like obviously
this is not only racist but it's just
like
it's
treating people in a way that they
should never be treated no matter who
you are
and
it's obvious that you know he also has
some anger issues and uh you know did
the right thing by putting out a public
statement apologizing and kind of
agreeing to you know doing the standard
thing of i'm going to agree to talk with
leaders from the the mexican or latin
american community
but
you hope it doesn't stop there right you
hope it
that he actually learns from this and i
think there are probably a lot of people
who have
privately racist views or unfortunate
views
or potentially abuse or harass other
people in private and they'll never have
that reckoning or never have an impetus
to change
or think about changing or even consider
the fact that that's bad because in
certain communities certain age
demographics you know
a couple hundred years ago you wouldn't
have thought about it that way it just
wouldn't enter your head
and somebody could even come up you know
somebody could have called them out in
that moment and it wouldn't have had the
same effect as being publicly shamed i
just hope that it doesn't stop there i
just hope that
you don't just go away forever or that
you promise to change and or talk to
somebody and you don't that there's
actual reflection that there's actual
consideration of why it's bad to treat
people like that why it's bad to have
those kinds of attitudes because
ultimately you do hope for people to
progress and grow and learn i don't know
if that's asking too much
but uh
you know
when you see somebody who's a gym bro
who's on steroids or whatever and it is
chalked up to like he's an angry juicer
and it's like you know i know a lot of
jew sets who aren't racist
i know a lot of big dudes who are buff
and or armenians who aren't racist so
chalk it up to the individual and hope
he can change his individual
and
uh
i guess we'll be
we'll be waiting on that we'll be
waiting to hear back from him
and uh see how wokey gets in the next
few months
hey mark you're in a good mood you might
be saying
well that's because i am in a good boot
in fact you might say i'm a happy hippo
why because i get my kratom from happy
hippo herbals.com yes i still use kratom
every day yes i do it on my podcast
maybe not every day but let's say a few
times a week all right i use it
responsibly i like the way it makes me
feel i like the mood it puts me in i
like it as a nootropic that i can use
when i need to think and put words in my
brain outside of my mouth into the real
world so if that's something you think
you might enjoy doing i'm going to
encourage you to check out
and use happyhippoherbles.com code
thick boy with three c's for 20 off not
just this purchase but every single
purchase for the rest of eternity pass
it on to your children mark physically
you're firing on all
cylinders you might be saying to
yourself you got the hair going you got
the oak and stone shirt going but look
it's 90 degrees outside right now in los
angeles what are you doing wearing a
dark long sleeve
shirt in such heat well
i'll tell you oak and stone clothing is
actually very breathable and guess what
it pairs with a variety of things you
might be saying to yourself
are you wearing tuxedo pants under that
desk well
if you thought that you'd be wrong it
turns out i'm wearing short shorts
and my outfit looks cute af so you can
take a shirt like this you can dress it
up or you can dress it down
because guess what oak and stone
clothing
is made with the athlete in mind
and look i may not have ever been a
professional athlete but i was a
division three athlete
okay
athletes come in all shapes sizes and
calibers
and oak and stone stands with the
athlete acceptance movement
oh wait
use promo code hella at checkout for 10
off at oakenstoneclothing.com make sure
to keep that and do not cut it out just
because there was a
pause bros science academy
now
do you guys know coach trevor casey do
you know coach trevor
no who's coach
i sometimes honestly forget how
niche the world of fitness influencing
is but coach trevor is a guy who along
with dr tony huge has made
probably a bigger name for himself but
coach trevor is like his scientist a
sidekick right
we uh
he's somebody who i go to
he's like one of a few people where i'm
like you can actually teach me something
about anabolics
on youtube if you talk i'll listen a lot
of people regurgitate generic
information and i'm probably guilty of
that too i would think that i know and
speak from a place of
you know own personal experience that
also is you know coupled with what i've
read online but i'll always make it
clear like i haven't taken this
substance i have done this at this dose
and yada yada i i'm not
posing as an expert i do have a lot of
experience but a guy like this who's
been a coach and had thousands of
clients
uh you know when he speaks on compounds
or training or whatever i listen so one
of the things i saw a video of him
talking about was training unilaterally
he's a guy who was up to like 285 pounds
as a bodybuilder
and uh had a some sort of injury that
put him in a wheelchair he didn't go
into this video but i know part of his
history is
having uh had significant injuries and
that
he did something or he talks about
something in this video that
i've experienced myself which is the
need to train unilaterally that at other
times in my life i would get injured and
never go to the gym again right or or
during that period it could turn into
something much longer because even if i
was injured for a few weeks i'd get out
of the routine and then stop going to
the gym and let things backslide much
more than they needed to
as of late have had tricep injuries have
had pec injuries have had different
things that or even my you know chronic
shoulder issue
i've tried to not let that keep me out
of the gym even when i pulled a pec
muscle and it was very scary and part of
me wants to like just don't do anything
upper body for this time any pressing
motion whatsoever i force myself to get
in there and do things unilaterally
now he brings up a great point as to why
this is also just scientifically
beneficial not just getting into the
habit
of uh you know
keeping lifting even when you don't feel
like it or there's reasons not to
because it is inconvenient to lift one
side of your body
the reason is there are certain systemic
effects that happen from exercise that
the side you're not working will still
benefit from right
the hormone production right if you're
nanny and you work out heavy enough
you're gonna get growth hormone release
you're going to get testosterone release
you're going to get
you know
anti-inflammatory response that is
systemic and so part of that will go to
the side that you didn't even work
you're getting a full body benefit and i
think he quantified it like 16
or something
to that effect you know it's better than
nothing it's still something
and
in addition to that keeping up the
routine
it's something that i'm going to
encourage you to do and also look him up
if you guys have any questions about
gear and you're on youtube look up coach
trevor watching his videos dr tony huge
is a little bit wacky um it's you know
he's not a doctor at all
i think he has a juris doctor which
means you graduated from law school
does that make you a medical doctor
qualified to speak on anabolic steroids
probably not
but you know what does make you
qualified to speak about
liver is being the liver king actually
let's go to the other one did you open
that there we go uh
okay let's play this
continuous cooling but this is not
enough so i ordered 2 000 pounds of ice
but this
is not enough
more this is not enough
more
you gotta respect it man 36 degrees is
very cold very cold indeed
uh
painfully cold i love that he's got it
do you think that's a little fox hat or
something else yeah well ken let's go
with fox alright where'd you get the fox
from
i hope you didn't buy that fox from a
fox domestication program because those
foxes are all very friendly and meant to
be pets and that means you would have
spent upwards of ten thousand dollars
just to have a fox hat on your head
maybe it's fake who knows let's get to
the bottom of the story maybe i don't
know maybe someday liver king will come
on the pod
it's just a crazy idea but you know if
you wish and you pray and you speak with
god and believe that you are his son
magical things can happen
let's scroll down oh yes i love this
meme format of the gen z
on god yo liver is busting for real for
real and he's got the little what is
that a fade the curly haired is it is it
a rule that you can only have a fade if
you have that curly hair on top
don't care looks great and his beard is
busting for real for real too ong is on
god i don't know what do you think it is
i thought it was like an intentional
misspelling of omg
um
i don't know
oh my god your liver because i think
he's he's making a claim that's saying
on god this is true yeah that makes me
yeah so i just uh you know you learn
something every time you learn something
here on this podcast yeah it could be
oh my god yo liver is busting oh my god
y'all like oh my god i just i just bit
into some liver dude [ __ ] is busted for
real for braille
look i'm gonna take a step back and take
a step forward
[Laughter]
right now we gotta get this this is just
a little magical moment here that the
liver king has been caught going down
one of the gigantic slides
he's just
looks like he's having fun though one
thing you can say about liver king he
looks like he's having fun pretty much
all the time even when he's balls deep
in a super heavy workout or he's just
sliding his
giant muscles down a kid's water slide
in the
on his giant compound i was gonna say
backyard but it's like well he probably
has like hundreds of acres of property
and he'll put that [ __ ] wherever the f
he wants i don't know that our ancestors
have ever had this much
you know he actually addressed
uh
on logan paul
he talked they're like
the sidekick or whatever his name is
mike was kind of asking the devil's
advocate questions
which like i get that but also it's like
it kind of felt like all right and now
mike gets to ask like a tough question
it's like you guys should all just like
be asking out of curiosity so he's the
one who asked about you know or said he
was gonna ask about steroids liver king
actually preempted him but at some point
he asked about
you know the fact that social media is
not ancestral
the liver king had a great rebuttal to
that which is like dude like i'm trying
to have a better life do you think my my
life isn't better flying around in a
private plane do you think my life isn't
better sliding down this kitty slide on
my hundred acre compound but his point
was yo i do the liver stuff and like go
out in the cold and the heat to increase
my quality of life you know i'm taking
what works from the past but like also
you got a private plane for me sure dude
i'm not trying to you know walk across
the country to meet up for your podcast
so
that's something that i've thought about
before but i'm like oh the way when you
frame it like that like being like what
do we
what do we pick up that doesn't work and
we need to get rid of for our own
happiness sure i like that and i
continue to like his message generally
what do we got below that is that a
special little riley reed meme
she's not only the animal queen she's
the queen of memes in our hearts
on god you're about to make me bust for
rio no cap and so that famous thing
where she looks she's like oh my god
you're about to make me and then insert
whatever you know you're about to make
me
come you're about to make me
i can't think of any good examples right
now but this one is pretty tight oh god
you're about to make me bust for real
for real no cap
the kids all have that you know and she
looks kind of cute with that haircut i
gotta say
okay can we back up to this little i was
gonna do it under the uh
bro science academy that reel that you
clicked on
and basically
this is a video about how you work out
making all the difference
i can give the same program to a
beginner and to an advanced athlete the
beginner will tell me it's too easy the
advanced person will not be able to walk
the next day why is that well it's
because the advanced person knows how to
do progressive overload correctly they
will know how to challenge themselves
the ways they'll also perform the
exercises more proficiently meaning
their range of motion their intensity in
the actual training session is
appropriate for that workouts so this is
something that beginners have to learn
and it's not going to happen overnight
if you're a beginner you don't need a
harder training program you probably
need to master those other things first
nice and i couldn't agree more that
message as we talked about
a little bit earlier even if i'm doing
something as simple as leg press with
perhaps a sub optimal weight i can find
ways to make that more challenging for
myself and it's hard to
pass on certain things like people will
ask me for training programs now i
probably will come out with training
programs soon and i'm actually going to
start
doing some
consultations in the near future
um
for various sorts of things because i'd
like to formalize that process and as of
now i'm getting too much demand for kind
of the time you know i want to give it
out for free i do consult with a lot of
people free and just try to point them
in the right direction um but ultimately
i'd like to offer more and just set it
at a fair price or whatever somewhere
down the road
but you know
i need more information from people i
can give them a program but if that's
not going to tell me your intensity your
range of motion your breathing all these
little things and i am still learning
and paying attention to
uh that make that point stand you can do
a very simple workout
you know more complex doesn't mean
better as we've been over many many
times
but you can always improve even on the
machines even on a bench press machine
you can find ways to pimp that machine
just like i found ways to pimp your mom
you can always find ways to improve and
impregnate that machine to secondary
every machine at 24 hour fitness got
pregnant this morning on god for real
for real um
but yeah that's a great little video
because it's like dude
programming
that's a pretty simple element i can
tell you what to do but
you know unless i'm there in person for
a thousand dollars an hour which is my
minimum range
that'd be sad if i could actually charge
it
i would feel bad but not really if you
had the money it wouldn't feel bad
i have female trainer friends who are
like guys want to work out with me like
they live in san francisco and they're
like uh
and i get these tech guys who are like i
want you to train me they're like all
right double like what they normally
charge girls
you're getting training and a show but
it makes sense it's like well yeah you
know
you want a hot ass girl to train you
pay up mother effa
so
a lot of people been asking me about
cialis this is actually true because i
brought it up on t5k the other day uh i
get it from lralabs.com
use code hella checkout
which is after i give a shout out
they're like hey you want an affiliate
link um it is a really good
website to get all this stuff from
peptides you know male enhancement stuff
uh your pct anybody who asked me about
pct i always send them there for the
clone of fee and hcg it's good stuff
they're super reliable i've just been
using them for years so like there's a
lot of
quality websites out there it's just the
price point is fair
shipping is really fast super reliable
anytime i've ever had an issue they're
always on top of it making sure i get my
stuff and you know that's really the
battle with
getting stuff online is like can i trust
it is it gonna come
um
that's never a question with your mom
though oh
all right can we click this link under
here under hell is psychological it's
time to get super psychological
the problem with body positivity let's
just read these key points here because
that's probably all i read anyway when i
took the screenshot of this and said to
myself body positivity teaches
acceptance of all types of bodies your
own and others sometimes body positive
messages can feel more controlling than
helpful research finds
especially if they challenge your
autonomy you can choose to listen only
to body positive messages
you believe in and that suits your needs
let's go down to the first paragraph at
least then the body positivity movement
which grew out of the late 1960s fat
acceptance movement
strives for acceptance of all body types
regardless of skin color size shape or
physical ability and encourages all
people to love except embrace their
appearance but what began as a seemingly
important and altruistic social movement
to help people women in particular
love the skin they're in and accept
themselves
regardless of what they look like and
regardless of any stigma surrounding
their appearance has been showing its
downside now we gotta find out what the
downside is
researchers at clarkson university have
found that messages sent to women
encouraging them to be body positive
aren't always supportive often fall flat
and can often leave people feeling more
depressed and unsure of themselves
that's because the messages can
sometimes seem controlling diminish
autonomy and ultimately do more harm
than good when you're seeking support
and acceptance the body positive
messages you hear or give yourself can
only improve your self-esteem and
diminish shame if they also support your
basic need not only to gain acceptance
from others
but also feel you are able to make your
own decisions and stand behind them
without feeling like you're simply doing
what others are doing or tell you to do
when that's not the case positivity
messages feel controlling i think that's
really interesting because
it can
you know when you start to say like
this it's okay to be fat or whatever
it's is it also a signal saying like
don't try hard to get skinny
people criticize other people for
working out too much right
i've been criticized for working out or
being too handsome you know it's not
something that i can necessarily control
but i feel like it's my choice to look
this good so what is your issue with it
i agree with this general sentiment
because it's sentiment because it it
covers so many things broadly
when you're autonomous it just feels
better right even if people are
sending you positivity if you can tell
they're only positively reinforcing you
because you're overweight and what if
you were to lose weight it wouldn't be
the case you know
i think there's a chasm between
fat shaming
and fat positive or
you know fat acceptance
right
that somewhere in the middle might lie a
good
medium which isn't always the case for
two differing things but in this case
it's sort of like
do i think we should go out of our way
to shame people
no i don't i don't think shaming works
whether it comes to addiction and i do
think food you know isn't it i think
there's science backing up the notion
that
uh you know people can
exhibit all the same behaviors and
psychology of somebody with a drug
addiction when it comes to food
do shaming drug addicts work
not so much it seems because you have to
build up other things your your
self-esteem your you know sense of
competence your sense of community
all these other things that contribute
to the happiness
that would replace the drugs that is
your only source of happiness so
do i believe in fat shaming you know do
i believe in just going online and you
know telling people they look fat or
kind of you know even like the jordan
peterson thing when he comes out and
tweets about this girl being on the
cover of si and
saying she's not beautiful i just like i
don't care to do that i don't think it
needs to be said i think enough people
kind of like think it already you know
and some guys do find that attractive
good for you but that's different than
you know i don't like the shaming but
also like let's not go overboard with
the acceptance because as you just see
it becomes a whole different negative
thing
where people feel like
you accept me when i'm fat like but do
you accept me at any weight do you
accept what i want to do
and therein lies the important message
and the real important
lesson for me is
do what you want
you know
what body do you want what makes you
feel good
i would never encourage anybody to take
steroids or to lift weights or do any
form of specific exercise or take
anything and put it in their body
if they didn't want to i'm happy to
guide people who are curious about that
or have made the decision to go down
this road of gaining muscle or using
anabolics or
doing xyz that i could probably provide
help with but the notion of pushing
somebody or making it seem like if you
don't do this you're going to lose my
acceptance
that's not great for society that's not
great for individual happiness because
again it robs you of autonomy and i
think it's manipulative at the end of
the day if you're conditionally
accepting of somebody
because they help reinforce your ego
because if you're overweight or you know
in my case if i use anabolics and i want
other people to use anabolics and
because it makes me feel better
i remember taking a year off drinking in
college
for no reason you know
aside from
[Music]
throwing up in a closet in lake tahoe on
new year's day no not in the cla i slept
in the closet and then just stayed there
for the rest of my life
that's a gay joke
about myself
i did get really hungover and i was like
why am i doing this i don't even like
drinking that much and i stopped
drinking for a year
the issues that people had with that it
was it was mind-blowing people just
can't stand to see you at a party not
drinking they're like what are you doing
why don't you just have one when you
know are you not go home you have a
problem are you not a lot of drink
you're taking a medication like they had
all sorts of questions it made people
uncomfortable because we want other
people to do the same thing that we're
doing
so that we don't
self-reflect and feel self-conscious
same sort of thing here
i know that being in shape can make
other people feel uncomfortable i've
i've discovered that even if they don't
say it directly you find out like oh
this person like you walked in and
they're like you know they project on to
you and again that's not even like
i'm not one of these people who goes
around
thinking this person's looking at me
wrong because i'm buff it's like no no
their friends told me that you know or i
found out about it in some direct
indisputable fashion and i go oh yeah
like
i didn't intend to do that but it made
me uncomfortable if i were to fit in and
look like the other people here it
wouldn't be an issue but suddenly it is
so
if you're fat and you don't want to be
fat
do something about it and [ __ ] everybody
else who has an opinion about it
or who's going to put up any sort of
resistance to you doing exactly what you
want and having the body that you want
and if you're ready to make that body
transformation go to hellamargarly.com
don't you dare try to buy that domain
name don't you dare turn this down
um
you know what's crazy
how we have a whole another segment how
much time have i spent ranting about
wokeness today 35 minutes oh my goodness
you know
this is going to be the political
episode
in this segment called hello political
because we look at the intersection of
fitness with all things i get to talk
about transgenderism today yay
with regards to your mom
[Music]
she's not a real woman oh
how are you born i don't know
out of your dad's urethra ah
your dad's a hyena oh
female hyenas have giant clitorises
i can't i'm not gonna i'm not gonna owe
that one
that's right draw the line dude
so the world governing body for swimming
has dropped the absolute hammer on a
swimmer with a hammer
hey
um
no this has been in the news and the
swimmer whose name i didn't bother to
memorize because it's not even that
important all we need to know is a
transgender swimmer
uh won at least one ncaa championship
and then it's arguable whether or not
she threw the other ones but she had
you know the potential seemingly to win
multiple ncaa championships but after
the controversy of her first battle it's
debatable that she
threw the other matches right but
regardless it opens up this
question obviously it's an ethical moral
question of whether it's fair to
everyone it opens up scientific
questions of
gender differences in sports performance
and to relate it back to me bringing up
that definition of woke
let's start with the intuitive response
to that i think the intuitive response
that most people have is
well
if women's times in swimming are across
the board slower than men's
throughout history when you're looking
at elite swimmers
one would assume that there are gender
based performance differences
that statement that intuitive statement
has become a very taboo thing to say and
repeat
so therefore our definition of wokeness
earlier it's taking unintuitive stances
and saying if you don't believe that
you're a bad person right it's not not
i'm going to convince you why and i
haven't heard that compelling of an
argument other than
a governing body might make a rule that
a transgender you know athlete can
comply with
uh you know but we're seeing and i
honestly i don't worry about this stuff
people kind of get outraged about it if
you think
um you know
transgender male to female swimmers or
any athlete shouldn't compete with
females uh because they have an
advantage
i don't
buy into the notion that it needs to be
this like like there's already enough
outrage even from just her teammates and
that's who i kind of empathize with this
like that would feel bad if she's
knocking you out of your varsity spot or
you're
finishing second place like that i
empathize with
those people who i would consider to be
the victims of this unfairness right
and obviously everyone's still trying to
work it out and find the best solution
possible we were in the infancy of even
dealing with this kind of stuff but i do
think
with regards to swimming
there's a sort of easy solution which is
you can just compete with the men you
can compete in an open division which
the governing body is proposing to make
because look i used to swim
competitively and
i didn't ever think about winning so
much like i won races but i was that
that was the secondary goal the first
goal is to beat your times you know and
that's what i think most swimmers would
tell you is like you want to improve as
a swimmer as an athlete you know and
maybe that's a different demarcation
when
you transition and now you have a new
baseline and you can improve from there
you're never going to be as fast as you
were when you had testosterone pumping
through your veins but uh you can still
improve and find to join that outside of
you know
asserting an unfair advantage over
people
even with the this
the fighting stuff i remember the last
transgender fight that we saw
the
the biological female almost won
actually and i was like isn't that like
that's a that's a good thing you know
for women
because you could stand toe to toe even
in a fight even in something where
you're said to have all these
disadvantages from bone density and
reaction time and you know
just the the mechanics of your body
uh as a female aren't designed to make
you hit as hard or absorb punches as
well
as anybody who has the bone structure of
a man so
i think there's there's always different
angles to look at it but i think the
broad consensus now is one of fairness
you know
and uh and it's not disqualifying
anybody from competing it's just going
like hey man maybe let's not knock off
these people who
i think the observer the casual observer
up and down the board unless you have an
ideology that says otherwise says
eh i don't know if i like that
dude what do we look at the bottom let's
let's look at jcvd real quick john
claude van damme
i didn't know where to put this i just
wanted to showcase it because he is
still looking great for his age
he's lean he's limber he's flexible and
he's shirtless with his son
if you didn't know better you might
think this was a gay porn
said somebody walking into my room last
night oh
what else did i want to look at oh
goodness gracious
do we
get
oh let me see what this link is you know
sometimes i'll just put links here and i
have no idea
oh there we go no that's not the one i
want okay let's go to let's go to this
one
this one get up nice james this is what
i'm calling a natty backflip this guy's
on a bodybuilding stage
boom
why would you attempt
you know what reminds me of that uh
the afro ninja backflip remember that
was like one of the first viral videos
this dude you'll know what i'm talking
about if you're uh you know roughly my
age back in like 2005
this dude's doing like an audition right
and it's like oh god and it's on camera
and it's like yeah he looks at the
camera first and he's like he gives like
a what's up yeah e-bombs world oh yeah
old school he's kind of cocky he's like
what's up whoop boom it's the same thing
with the feet slip out from underneath
him
and then he goes he's concussed and he
goes he goes he goes right into the room
yes exactly it's all still there he's
just like
and then falls off are you okay so this
is basically the exact same thing except
it looks like me if i was natty
i could do a backflip can you i can
you know it's must be a lot of restraint
to have everybody asking chappelle to do
a backflip and you are just sitting
there silently going i can do it too i'm
a backflip guy you know what you are
you're the meme that nobody at this
party even knows i'm
able to do a backflip
man that that sucks because that guy's
not going to ever do a bodybuilding
competition again he walked off after
that and decided to live in the woods
with his cats
and speaking of cats
should i go and should i go into my cat
origin story or not let's do another
video from uh this is why we can't have
nice gyms here hold on let's look at me
yes
casey had that queued up surprisingly
damn that was quick too and then right
into yes
now how long have you been able to do a
backflip as long as i can remember damn
i grew up in a backflip family we can
all do backflips
you backflipped out of the womb actually
that is impressive and i can't believe
i've known you for this long like
usually people kind of lead with the
backflip that's that's exactly what uh
meatball said really i sent it to the
chat with me and chappelle yeah and and
meatball and it was like you're not the
only one who could do a backflip
chappelle yeah and meatball was like how
did you not lead with this exactly
i'm just gonna walk around being like
hey you know i can do a backflip yeah
but that is a testament to the fact that
casey's an international man of mystery
because he didn't leave with the
backflip and women love mystery you know
you can't just come out backflipping
like
backflip your [ __ ] into their pee
oh
my initial thought was wait do they
think i mean penis doesn't matter
it's whatever you want to have it mean
okay
p yeah that's
yeah
it's a unilateral gender
role all right
are you going to tell us about the i'm
getting word you know what you're
getting word here okay this morning
before the podcast me and casey talked
about how my
uh you did the thing that you do every
before everybody
did i talk about this yet you're like
and now you know i genuinely don't
remember and then i'm like oh but then
i'd have to go back and look for it so
i'm like like because it's harder for me
to be like i yes i remember having the
thought i thought about doing this
segment i thought about you know telling
this story but casey will actually
remember and in this particular case i
asked him did i tell you about the time
that i got peed on by a lion at the zoo
when i was a child and he's like i think
i would have remembered that so no
um and that was led into by me saying
this morning i had the realization
he-man's a cat guy i always think about
the 80s influences on me and like wanted
to be buff and i was like
maybe somehow thinking about that you
know with pro wrestling and these guys
who like
the role models of the 80s are buff
dudes right if you're a kid in the 80s
like you were like
being buff is the best thing you can be
and i'm a product of that and then i
also thought
hey man
had an impact on me thinking what an
ideal physique is for god and he also
had an impact on me making cats cool
because he had battle cat so like he-man
he's a cat guy yeah it's a tiger who
gives a [ __ ] it's still a cat
and then i thought oh wait my real
origin story though is
when i was six years old i went to the
portland zoo
we used to live in lake oswego portland
and
my dad most weekends would ask us if we
wanted to go to this
uh science sort of museum for kids omsi
i believe it was called
or the portland zoo because i think they
were
either next to each other very near each
other so
same direction same distance
and on this particular day we chose
the zoo and
of course you know lions are cool not
even if you're just into cats they're
just cool to everybody right so
the lions were behind plexiglass they
were behind
a cage right with bars like you know you
think of this like
do zoos even have cages anymore yes
apparently they do in 1989
and i remember
seeing the lion like he was you know
there's a male line walking back and
forth and there was a sign next to the
cage
that said something to the effect of
warning lions are in mating season
please stay six feet away from the cage
at all times due to spraying
right
and as i was reading that sign
i believe my dad called my name to like
watch out you know like mark watch out
which maybe
turn right into a stream of line urine
and all i remember was
being mystified that
i'm being peed on by a lion but i'm
looking at its [ __ ]
you know because lions like they spray
backwards or whatever
and i remember god i might like i
remember looking down at my shirt like
seeing the pattern you know that i'd
been zorro'd up
by lion piss and then my dad's like
grabbing me to like rush me out like
people were pointing at me and it was
like it was humiliating but it was more
like like chaotic you know i was like oh
yeah sure i had like my day at the zoo
and not like oh my god i just got beat
in my line
let's pretend that
lion urine is radioactive and that
turned me into who i am today okay let's
just go with that all right
big gay line or big gray line whatever
you want to go with right you know that
that line piss was mutagen that gave me
super big muscles
not the steroids that's what i say from
now on and also turn my hair gray okay
and also your mom's trans
[Music]
let's just do a couple more of these
gosh darn
this is why we can't have nice gyms
jeez
wait do we yeah dude
you know what this is why you got to ask
me this is right yeah this is why we
can't have this this is why we can't
have nice memes this is why we can't
have nice
this is the most pissed off cases ever
been to me during an episode
uh
this guy's benching what looks like
315 plus a couple tens so let's say
355
that would be my guess he fails and
instead of rolling it off his body he's
just screaming out mom oh my god
and he's just such a like
she straddles him
mommy put the [ __ ] on his face
and she can't lift it up off his chest
you gotta prepare for situations like
this she tries your best
yeah okay okay
what's funny is yeah he ends up dumping
it at the end
that's such a [ __ ] move i'm sorry
he's like mommy mommy
put your vagina on my face as i dump the
weight off to the side
and let's just go on to the final meme
of the day right here
it reads out when the entire universe is
giving you a sign of what you need to do
we have camera diaz we have skeletor we
have spider-man we have that dude from
the reality show cameron diaz
wait i thought it was the actress is it
i thought it was the whole time really
in the the cat this one like oh it's
like some reality thing is it really i
don't think it's camera i thought it was
from a movie no you could hit us in the
comments you're mostly let us know is it
cameron diaz i don't think it is mark
that's that's one of those things where
you go like oh
three years ago i made the decision that
it was cameron diaz and now i'm
reevaluating everything i've ever done
in my life uh you know but we also have
leonardo dicaprio so at least one a-list
actor there
casey's making me re-evaluate everything
including my sense of reality and uh
how well i can
differentiate between faces but what are
they all pointing at here
one message blast gear blast gear okay
and so if the universe is pointing at
you like this
that means you should dm me to figure
out how to blast gear all right
mark harley out
you